you
everyone is jerry manly chest org and
i'm going to do a group of three puzzles
and share my thoughts along the way i
thought we could do one from each of
these three categories let's start with
a an easy one
based on current puzzle rating and i
thought as a little bit of an adjustment
to these type of videos i can actually
put put myself on a clock and just
devote five minutes to each puzzle five
minutes of my time and see you know if I
could get it within five minutes even if
it's wrong I'll devote five minutes of
my attention to each of these puzzles so
let me go ahead and start the clock on
this one right now okay so team light my
eye is immediately focused on this
diagonal and the night moving the night
moves that would be a discovered check
quite possibly a double check night age
six would be the most forceful move King
AJ and that would leave the rook on FA
unprotected so we could take the rook
and then the knight ass has to block
that's the only move and then we take
the rook excuse me that we take the
knight on g8 so this is a mate puzzle
this is the most forcing move in chess
double check King must always move or
capture yeah the king must always move
let's just say in double check so King
tonight h6 King in the corner rook takes
rook check the knight must block and
then we could take the knight its
defended by our knight hand our bishop
okay let's put that one on
rook takes rep and then retake the night
all right not bad on that one
I'll give it a narrow up and let's see
where this puzzle was pulled from what
game this one was from this was a game
this puzzle was pulled from a game in
July of 2013
let's see how he got there i Kings key
what was it what was the opening Kings
gambit declined
Queens Knight defense okay let's see I
get there pretty quick
d5 takes takes and there we go it's a
mating three did white get it
check check me they got it okay cool
let's try another one from now the
normal group and let me go ahead and
start the clock on this one right now so
that first one wasn't didn't take too
long so I imagine they will become more
difficult so let's see white to move hmm
okay well my first thought is to chase
the defending piece away this is the
defensive piece he has a job it's
pressure on the rook so Bishop here at
the very least wins the exchange King
takes bishop King takes rook however I
don't know if that's a win yeah that
be pretty tricky to win that ending I
think there's something better here huh
oh oh we don't go in this direction we
go here huh yeah we don't have to give
up the bishop bishop check here is
sufficient
there is no pawn block because the pawn
is pinned and yeah we're just winning
the rook for free then so bishop here
the King moves to one of these two or
the rook plays here those are the only
options and we either take the rook like
that or with the king okay this one
wasn't too bad check and then we take
the rook okay
I'll give that one error up let's just
see where this one was pulled from that
first one probably a bit more
instructive since it's right out of the
opening but in these endgame puzzles who
knows what opening they came from right
but I still interesting to see where
these puzzles are filled from how the
game went this one was played in
December of 2013 and officer colored
bishop type position and somehow black
got all tangled up placed the rook in a
position where their pieces were
restricted and white did not come up
with the correct continuation rook g3
instead of bishop g1 was played and what
was the result a draw no black went on
to win this one yeah I resigned okay
let's have a look at one last one from
now the hard group so let me go ahead
and start the clock right now okay team
okay team black in this one so the pawns
are going this way
okay got it hmm well black needs to
somehow successfully promote this pun
how do you make that happen hmm
the immediate push huh what's the trick
with this one if we are to let's just
say push right away hmm
but light will give a check if you push
and the rook comes over here black
simply pushes again rook takes pawn rook
takes Queen King takes Queen the bishops
there to still watch over that important
remaining pawn white will be able to
hunt down this pawn with the King and
then finally push through but I believe
after push there would be rook check and
then what do you do if you block with
the bishop hmm if you block with the
bishop then this pawn could be taken not
right away
like for example push rook check bishop
block rook here is threatening to win
this pawn and then this one hmm with the
first move the bishop here threatening
to
push twice hmm this is tricky and two
minutes 15 seconds into this one so
let's see I'm not sure what more to
consider not too many candidate
candidate moves here Bishop to one of
these two pawn push is what I'm pretty
much thinking as they first move hmm
maybe maybe on push rook check Bishop
here rook a6 and then maybe we have the
move Bishop Bishop to d5 hmm that's a
loose piece the one that could be
challenged have less than two minutes to
try and sort this from now whether or
not I get it right and let's see hmm I'm
not sure what more to consider I think
I'm missing some important idea here
bishop blocks or just bishop here right
away and I don't see how that is really
helping I don't think it would be a king
move I have about a minute 15 left oh
let's see let's consider this once more
push check would it be a king move at
that point a - look check then
oh I do see it I think oh I got it
oh I got it finally okay a two rook
check came here I'm not I wasn't
initially seeing this new possibility I
wasn't seeing that we have a new legal
move as soon as the phone is not on a
three we have King a three so a two and
on rook check we have King a three and
we're threatening to Queen next and on
an ensuing check rook to a6 we can then
play Bishop a4 and he cannot be stopped
all right um pretty much locked into
that and my five minutes are up right
now so let me move forward with this is
it right it is and then King here this
one wasn't so bad actually
I was just missing this idea of push and
then the king having that new square
available the bishop now gets to block
and then we get to Queen next and that
should be the end of the puzzle that is
okay that one wasn't too bad
let me see where we got this one from
this was a game played between computer
was playing on the white end and this
one a computer with rating 1600 okay
yeah messy okay but yeah let's just go
through it real quick here see how we
got to that position almost there
did black come up with that winning
continuation let's see the puzzle
position came about right here did they
push
they did and on this move now they just
queen oh well excuse me
after push the rook did not come over
and give check yeah and if they did they
would go here but coming right over you
could just promote and I was I was
pointing out the king is then able to
come over here hunt down that pawn and
then get a new queen and then win like
so okay interesting group of three I
think this is something for this how to
solve chest puzzles playlist I'll try to
I'll try to incorporate some type of a
clock so it's the videos don't become
too too excessive with me kind of you
know repeating myself over and over I
think just giving about five minutes
devoting five minutes of my thoughts on
each puzzle is is something pretty
decent feel free to leave any comments
any feedback on on that and as usual I
hope you got something out this video so
thanks for tuning in and I'll catch you
in the next one that's all for now bye
bye
you